all right a little monday afternoon
quarterback
how about this one
and
we we saw the cardinals
up ten to seven
driving
fourth and goal from the one yard line
with three seconds left in the first
half and uh we lost shereen
they decided the cardinals did instead
of kicking the field goal that would
have made it 13-7 they decided to get
the walk-off touchdown and it did not
work the patriots stuffed it and
something sim said yesterday while we
were watching the games and i think he's
absolutely right a 10-point lead at that
juncture of the game may have been more
than what the patriots could have
overcome but it ended up being one of
the pieces in the puzzle that led to the
patriots upsetting the arizona cardinals
jarring to see a team like arizona
favored to win in new england but that's
the way it's gone this year for the
patriots that's the way it's gone for
the cardinals but now the cardinals 0
and 2 since the hail murray of 15 days
ago and they are in danger of tumbling
out of the playoff picture altogether in
the nfc the division highly unlikely at
this point
wild card spot possibly slipping out of
their grasp as we have teams like the
49ers and the vikings making a late push
toward the end of the season cardinals
and buccaneers need to be worried that
playoff spots that we thought were
presumed to go to them could end up over
the final 25 of the season going
somewhere else all right the carolina
panthers had the vikings beaten the game
was
it was an amazing game from the
perspective of how quickly the momentum
changed the viking score field goal to
go up 10-7 at halftime they get the ball
to start the second half they could go
up 17-7 and begin the process of putting
the pesky panthers away well
kirk cousins gets sacked ball comes out
jeremy chin scores a touchdown next play
from scrimmage for the vikings dalvin
cook in a mess of bodies ball comes out
jeremy chin scores a touchdown back to
back plays from scrimmage chin defensive
touchdown for the carolina panthers
vikings kept fighting though
to get back into it and they made it
24-21
all they had to do was force the
panthers to punt
get the ball back move the ball down the
field potentially tie it up chad bibi
fumbles the punt muffs it technically
panthers get it and this was amazing if
the game was over at that point folks
turn out the lights panthers have the
ball
first and goal from the nine
with two minutes and 10 seconds left
and the vikings have
one timeout
so
panthers run on first down
clock goes down to two minutes two
minute warning gives the vikings a
stoppage then with two minutes left
second a goal from the five
mike davis gains two yards
vikings take their final timeout 156 to
play
well at that point if you're the
panthers and you run the ball and you
don't score
you can take another 40 seconds or so
off the clock making it even harder for
the vikings to get down the field and
take the lead with a late touchdown
instead the
panthers choose to throw the ball it
doesn't work
the
clock stops on the incompletion field
goal try makes it 27-21 vikings end up
having more than enough time even with
no timeouts to get down the field and
score the game winning touchdown they
had so much time that it gave the
panthers time
to get themselves in position for a
potential game-winning field goal i
doubt that was part of the strategy for
matt rule when he managed the clock the
way he did at or around the two minute
warning here's rule's response when
asked about that possession after
yesterday's game
we ran the ball on first down went to
the two-minute warning ran the ball on
second down to get them to use their
last timeout
and um had it been at the two yard line
i would have gone for it you know uh at
the three
um we hadn't had much success with those
type plays yet so figure take the points
make them have to score a touchdown
and an extra point
um
uh you know with with them having no
timeouts left so that was the thought
process
um
you know had they had they scored with
five seconds left i would you know say
maybe i should have run the ball on
third down um i thought we had a good
play he was wide open we just weren't
able to connect on it i thought a
touchdown would end the game
fourth down and sort of take the points
make them score a touchdown they scored
so quickly that i don't know that i can
relate it back to any of those things at
least gave us a chance to have the ball
back
at the end
and it ultimately did give them the ball
back at the end and they did have a
chance to win but but it was stunning to
see
the panthers not take every last second
they could off the clock before the
vikings got the ball back even in an
empty stadium the vikings are at home
and the vikings had the offense to get
the ball down the field and part of the
problem too is the way that the panthers
played the vikings on that final drive
no blitz no pressure vikings carved them
up i mean they were at the 10 yard line
before you knew it to the point where
they left too much time on the clock for
the panthers to get in position to
potentially win the game one more though
chargers clock management the end of the
game down 27-17 with no timeouts they
hit
on a hail mary pass with a minute left a
55-yard pass to ty johnson they get the
ball in position
and then they run
they run
they run the ball
on a moving clock when you're down 10
you don't spike it you run it and the
clock keeps moving and that was pretty
much that for the chargers and it feels
like that's going to be that
for anthony lynn as much as i respect
coach lynn they were 12-4 a couple of
years ago but they were 12-4 with so
many close games and that's one thing
that philip rivers said after that
season we could have been 16-0 we could
have been six and ten with all the close
games they just happened to win most of
them since then a lot of close games
that they aren't winning and with justin
herbert and that defense that's centered
around joey bosa this is an attractive
job and i have a feeling it's going to
come open after the season and the
chargers are going to find someone who
will take justin herbert make him into a
franchise quarterback and maybe the
chargers become the preferred team in
los angeles
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports